ah
the iphone 12 powered by the a14 bionic
processor this phone has made its mark
as a very capable and solid mobile
device so with that how does it fare in
terms of gaming performance
well my fellow geeks you guys have come
to the right place here at the geek labs
we'll be testing out a few games
including pubg ganshin impact call of
duty mobile and more all in the highest
settings so you can decide whether the
iphone 12 is the right phone for you of
course if you guys would like to see a
particular game do check out the time
stamps in the description below so
without further ado i'm just gonna keep
quiet and just enjoy the gameplay let's
start with call of duty mobile
just for funsies
and of course i got the mech safe
charger
behind snapped in
so we can get a little bit of
performance while the battery runs
audio graphics so graphics quality very
high
frame rate let's put it at max
with anti-aliasing on
so yeah
i'm not just just put everything on max
and we'll see how it runs
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
targeted
[Applause]
hey
all right
there we go yeah
nice and smooth
uh
mix it all well for me no drop frames or
whatsoever connectivity was great
and yeah all this entire settings
everything turned on so
so here we have pubg
and
we are running it on smooth with extreme
frame rate
do note that the high frame rate is
basically if you have something that's
90 hertz and above
[Music]
right
[Music]
while running down
nice nice
so you can see the gameplay here is
pretty smooth it is on the smooth uh
quality settings so
it's just what the community would like
to see
and it's running pretty well actually
yeah
so you can see we're taking a quick
drive
um the gameplay is very smooth
you have no
uh sudden texture pops or anything like
that so it's good
just going back to save my friends
[Music]
guys got that on camera
cool
no looks like we're gonna win this one
let's see
oh
well done win a chicken dinner
all right oh we should not put that on
camera
that's very inappropriate
well yeah run again cool didn't do much
all right so here we got asphalt 9
very
graphic intense
racing game s49 legends yeah
well is that usually your
hands will be cupping the volume uh
speakers
so
gonna be mindful of that
can do that oh [ __ ]
no
[Music]
that's how we do
so we are running the game on this
default settings it looks pretty slick
as we look around the graphics looks
pretty cool pretty
pretty well done
so oh let's just uh
give it a spin shall we
there are a few of these statues
scattered across the land to show the
seven's protection over the world among
the seven gods
[Music]
and there's the reason why
cool
that's cool
there's something huge
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
oh so we got some choppiness there
[Music]
getting pretty leggy
[Music]
yeah
definitely something like here
iphone's getting pretty warm too with
the mac safe plugged in
so
yeah
[Music]
as you can experience there's something
like this
let's give an iphone uh the rest it
needs it's getting pretty warm with the
mag6 charger so
yeah
let's
get shin impact for you
hopefully it doesn't run this warm and
this laggy for you guys
so what we got here is vainglory another
well received
game in ios um everything is running
here on default settings anyway because
there's
nothing here to
increase the performance so
all the quality actually so
yeah let's just play the game let's go
for blitz quick one
right so graphics looks pretty damn good
actually wow
the glows the ambient occlusion
wow he actually looks pretty pretty neat
uh it is playing in 60 frames everything
looks nice and fast paced
it's quite impressed a little bit of
frame jumps here
looks pretty good though
[Music]
[Music]
sound is nice as always oh snap
[Music]
why can't i attack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
nope
[Music]
oh wow really
[Music]
[Music]
uh wow
[Music]
huge
[Music]
[Music]
oh man
i'm gonna knock back
mom
can we get one more kill
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
watching
[Music]
everyone
well there you have it folks
so gaming on the iphone 12
how does it perform well
yes and no
if you're looking into casual gaming
perhaps playing games on the apple
arcade or if you don't mind playing
games in either its lower or default
settings then you have a very good
chance at having real good fun playing
games on the iphone 12. however if
you're more of a hardcore mobile gamer
but still one a solid apple device you
can consider other options such as the
ipad pro with its 90hz refresh rate
display and if that is still on the
pricier side then you can also consider
playing games on the ipad air
alternatively the iphone 12 might be a
better option but if you're looking for
performance to value the iphone 12
really hits the sweet spot for most
folks well that's pretty much it if you
guys enjoyed this video don't forget to
give us a thumbs up and do consider
subscribing and smash that notification
bell icon so you can stay updated to our
latest geeky news and tidbits until then
this is zacky